it's a place for all Canadians in Canada's
game here's a lead pass to tricep from Kane
stop made flurry coming off a win over the Chicago
Blackhawks yeah they really took off once he took
over one four in a row and in that game last
night I mean they dominated that first period
but ended up being down one Nothing by the end of
it Carolina coming in here after they played the
Winnipeg Jets and they dominated that game in
my opinion great performance by Laur bris for
Winnipeg in that one and give the conu some
credit they found a way to weather the storm
early on find the scoring when they needed then
close it out in the end but that was the first
loss under John Hines in a game in what you
look at and say it most likely should have
had a little bit better result didn't find it
the Vander K lead pass this time Brown a chot
and that hit the side of the net crowd reacted
thought it was in but it hit the side of the net
and Louis from your angle that must have been a
little difficult as well here's a drive by Brown
and a save made by FL in a big hop R tried to F
it out the corner EOL bottled it up kep control
weaving turning firing and another save made
by blurry that's five shots on net flurry has
handled them all great pinch down by aom McDavid
and that was towed aside by flurry for a moment
Freddy gdr's on it for Minnesota and he'll lob
it little behind kulak he's able to pick it up
and fire a pass G's blast save made by blur a
great surge up the ice by Darnell Nur started
with a great poke check in the defensive Zone set
the puck forward he just plowed through everyone
here's a centering pass and a tough save on
Harman Joe Hing around the boards Freddy good Ro
feathered back to the point favor rossing a shot
and that's handled by Skinner off the boards cut
off by Johansen but Brak wide that's going to
lead to a chance for Ev two on two two McDavid
drop pass a drive blocked by broin here's F hits
the trailer and what another block Middleton saved
the C goal Newen opkins find Bart shoots and
scores Edmonson finally breaks through what
nothing continue to generate chances McDavid off
the rush has the first one this one block recovery
it's Bard active up the ice that sends that to
Newen Hopkins another great chance and then a
beautiful pass by newon Hopkins as he finds Bard
back door hesitates for a second gets the blocker
to go down Elevate up over top of the glove under
the bar 10 games in a row now for buar with a
point as he extends his streak Conor McDavid with
eight now I believe out to the top of the circles
you complete a pass through that area you're in
trouble shot sto by flurry 20 seconds left on
the man Advantage One Tim atan saving rebound
another save flurry shot by n another save Mar
Andre flurry here's some great chances at the
end of this period in a couple you were talking
about that first one great save flurry dishes
it out makes a second that one by nurse tried
to elevate it advice that put up a few points
in the National hock League from a defensive
perspective one of the best ever had a chance
to chat as a shot taken by fa dropped in front
and tucked home for The Equalizer mat he just tied
it we'll take a look here at how this happens how
does Eric s get in that tight to steuart Skinner
now here it is here as he gets around and yeah no
there's nothing there I thought from the look at
steuart Skinner's face now there was a stick that
came in we'll watch that but this looks on first
take like a clean goal and he's just fighting on
the edge of his grease and it's a good job by
Eric X strong stick to pound that puck over and
win a battle and baly funneling to the net jams
at home no chance for steuart Skinner didn't know
where it was 12th overall pick in 2019 number 12
dishes what ti score Eric Sak off the rush 2-1
Minnesota with two goals in the first 41 seconds
well I'd love to know what John hin said between
periods to this Minnesota Wild team cuz they have
woken up in a big way in the start of this second
period just off the entry gets lost through the
The Interchange Eric s Baldi goes to the middle
you're going to see Eric s kind of funnel through
and he's left alone for that Split Second it's why
you interchange as forward you're trying to make
that happen and it happens here Rossi he wheeled
it up and Minnesota able to convert off the rush
Nan Hopkins speaking about out my pass McDavid
Cuts in Waits Waits TS it home Conor McDavid
a virtuoso game time goal his ninth and it's
22 he just talked about a watch this Newen
Hopkins finds him up the ice it's a two-on
one as the Minnesota Wild get a little aggressive
but watch this patient stick handle stick handle
get flurry to bite you know Mark Andre flurry's an
aggressive Bender wants to come out and challenge
that's exactly what he does but the patience the
skill of Conor McDavid to walk this around tuck it
home on the backhand side and tie the game what a
response I'm and trying to elevate and flurry get
the toe on it so a good decision I think Dr for
shooting a steal and a denial of James Hamlin by
Mark Andre flurry GI a steel Hartman stole it
right back do around the boards Hartman tucked
it inside Duane out to the point for fa his shot
off the kneecap of G behind Harman in front what
timer score it's 32 Minnesota some kind of finish
fourth line of the wild doing some good things
and it's off the cycle using the back of the net
protecting the puck here here's Dam with a nice
read just to kind of hold on to it find it this
pucks up for grabs again great play right there
from behind the net just an excellent effort to
get this Puck out and you're going to see this
spinorama pass by Gad and he finds dur in the
high slot and he Harman sorry not boar no shot
gets it back fakes again McDavid new J Hopkins one
timer I will ties it there's the exaltation three
all brand new hockey game early on they weren't
able to isolate him and expose him but watch this
they start to go back and forth around him they
know he doesn't have a stick getting a little
bit closer each time and eventually they're going
to find the onetime for ddle you can see this now
they know that he doesn't have the stick they're
pretty confident holding on to that puck creeping
down the zone and eventually it's dry CLE we
talked about it when he's sniffing playing the
way he's playing it's only a matter of time
and it's a beautiful pass nen Hopkins to dry
cidal and flurry show discipline poo doesn't have
a stick so 5 by three and a half again like David
tried to tuck it inside it's clear but not out
board knocked it down with Bo TR hkin firing on
the rebound got it to D on what timer ping home
Bard and Edmonton regains the lead 4 to three on
a 97 mph Blazer what makes this power play so
successful snap it around there's a block stay
with it put it into a corner set it up again
and then look at that the fly by screen Felino
trying to get into the way to block this Blast by
Bard maybe puts a little bit too much of a screen
on the glove head side Spurgeon and Middleton
trade trying to toss it in but off a linesman
here's McDavid with Newen Hopkins centers Newen
Hopkins denied from the 39-year-old McDavid to
Newen Hopkins no the Capri on trying to
rake that puck free chisling carving and
finally dealing it BL wide open shot off the
post from post after this battle here and it
was a long time in the corner finally digging
out that bouncing Pucket was actually chopped
by an orderer I believe trying to get it out
of there and it goes right to Harman that's
Zinger able to nudge it back through Center
sent across Steel by atom he was taken down
they're letting him play they'll finish with
7 Seconds one last chance so gell J is what
a save Skinner at the hord Edon survive he's
going to boil over here four and he makes his
best save of the game because it's stopped
it from being tied that one timer kicks it
away up into the air and the final buzzer goes
on a bouncing puck made another one for good